I can't even do rhythm Jesus
the white leave your memes on the reddit
nineteen-year-old
measure upp so WI 4,000 dominoes
preparing yourself a small peepee I'm
ready I'm ready
what does this mean review what is this
one gonna say no why
what hell yeah
obviously huge peepee don't even pretend
my mom's reaction to her in new Isla why
not much has changed
I think this channel is always
innovating always switching it up what's
he gonna do next floor Gameboy build
your furniture Lawai mom as a Swedish
person nothing bothers me more than
unbuilt furniture it makes me
she's cancelled I'm sorry I'm sorry Ella
why mom don't criticize my dog he has
special needs he can't help it
[Music]
just build your goddamn furniture now I
want to full-on video building that
tutorial furnish or whatever alright
Pierce accidentally reveals emails to a
hundred thousand people on livestream
periods 0.005 milliseconds later I'll
forgive ya first it was the game's fault
and then it was my fault
because I'm smart like that check out my
livestream guys to see what else I'm
gonna mess up it's inevitable at this
point so yeah make sure to become a
member you get epic emotes let's let's
be real you don't have a big peepee
unless you get the epic emotes Edgar had
to go to the vet yesterday how is Edgar
he's safe is he alright Edgar hey come
on I know you sleepy come on
vlog a you get to eat the tambourine
it's fine
he had some stomach problems he's okay
thank you for asking
oh my god that is massive fifi so for
this you don't know they finally shipped
they got delayed because of bets I'm
sorry so we decided to put a number on
each one of the orders and they asked me
if I wanted the number one one I'm like
now the fans should have it the bro
should have it that's cool I'm glad I'm
glad it's in safe hands what the hell I
don't remember this guess I'll have to
watch Phineas and Ferb we will watch it
on the next livestream become a member
yeah I face what pills with some of his
favorite people oh god it took me way
too long to see what do you mean
favorite people I only love Ricardo I'm
sorry dr. Phil and blue shirt kid blue
shirt kid black bra
I wonder what blue shirt kid is doing
right now is he okay
Pierce revert is back to an old save
found baked that's a really big PP well
done such a reddit joke but it's still
funny
alright I spent a long time on it and
it's finally finished
enjoy the college right I'm reading it
before I'm watching like 500 pages Jesus
that's amazing so smooth
[Laughter]
rest in peace Papa Gloria this is so sad
she got hit by a treadmill
we got a hand-drawn mean over here see
no one cares how are you doing and why
do you not love me anymore can you see
it can you they see union camera
they can't ya look at you you're okay
it's a bit hot today I think that's why
yeah he wants to go back to his spot but
I get the fan not yet girl okay [ __ ] oh
you're back Bengt coming home and seen
Felix with me are they both alive oh
yeah they are see no one dies on my
playthroughs keep watching for more
wholesome content gross beard how's it
going bros my name is beer 2pac plays
hurricane oh yeah it's all coming
together
oh yeah dude amnesia the new game is
coming out I'm so excited I want to be
as scared as the first time another one
it finally arrived and it has one of the
funny numbers on it 4:20 another one
another one Bravo Bravo sir or man or
whatever well done huge PP it cannot
state the size of this PP so large felix
desk arrived i feel like i review this
it's now mine clay loaf i hip hop mix
felix it's treason name no it isn't I'm
happy on the floor I feel good about it
Felix Lynx is a male cat down panic it's
okay he was we need to change emails
anyway and has another calm he likes it
yeah maybe there's life in thing wasn't
such a good idea
I'm such an idiot I can't help it I'm
just born and raised dumb very dumb dumb
small people no don't ever think for a
second that I'm small PP Congrats
PewDiePie on it's still up in Toronto
I'm so mad that I didn't see a I was
literally in that neighborhood my hotel
was around the corner Thank You G fuel
you've been nothing but a great partner
and we delivered a bang s product check
it out the pretty pie flavor
laying a berry flavor I drink it it's
the only flavor
I drink actually I may be a little
biased but it's a goddamn greatest Edgar
when Felix is around agent E when Felix
is not around what is this I don't
understand
move on thank you I can't wait to
finally watch finish the process was
just stopped and I can actually laugh at
it
flora gang ball game air gang ceiling
game I like these these are dope they
would look cool and like as I like a
military patch or something I don't know
Felix stop maiming me all right I had
enough with it females to block like 500
kids and big booby dating chat websites
like Thank You Felix
after leaking two of his email accounts
please don't kill me I'm stupid I can't
I told you I told you and you keep doing
it
god damn it Florida bulla bulla bulla
bulla I'm happy on the floor guys back
issues but issues issues in life no
problem if you're on the floor he
protect he attacked but most importantly
he gave again okay I'm back please
you gotta hit the tambourine Pullman
Brown come on the kids love it
there you go
now hit the tambourine yeah yeah you see
that
that was sick Thank You Edgar love you
lots
when you are listening to a song and it
turns out to be the song you've been
looking for but never knew the name of
it
it's called mine all day and you're
welcome people in 29 in 2020 youtubers
will be creative and original youtubers
in 2020
hey at least I never pretended to be
original alright everyone knows I have
no original ideas that's why they love
my videos because they can never be
disappointed
two things consistent me being an idiot
and Florida game that's it Firefox logo
evolution after watching minecraft Felix
minecraft series pink pink blackberry a
berry how to properly take a shower 2.3
million people before watching this test
now that's love right there
I haven't really followed the aftermath
after they broke up but from what I
heard he just went on TV and
trash-talked her real smooth smooth guy
Felix stop yelling at Sven the Kent 65
to 85 percent of blue-eyed white cats
are deaf meaning there's a considerable
chance that he just can't hear you well
I'll take the odds okay I'll take the
flip menage
you're dead is dead to me I've always
hated him two things consistent always
hated water sheep always hate that blue
eyes white dragon cat that's a good name
actually actually makes them a bit
likable I don't know that's weird
no no no no hang out amazing fan art yet
again this is what my ancestors would do
to survive see those strong long long
legs
we've just been evolving but backwards
ever since potential prepares to make
his this be a DJ and named him BJ that's
genius
I take everything back I am so sorry
your Clarion geniuses I'm sorry I'm
sorry
tambourine of forgiveness and tambourine
before gift next days Felix what the
floor is lava
so what I'll still commit to lava
I'm lava in floor gang Allah but see I
can make funny jokes laughs yeah that's
what I thought hey if anyone can do it
it's him ooh I knew it's working with
water cheap I knew it
I called Nate Felix's car ride it's not
mine plays low fly hip-hop makes Felix -
that right slow game so long partner she
took it that was the point of the thing
you're dumb again you're dumb again
revert apology resort to Paul okay I
keep doing it I'm sorry with piercing
siren head video I feel like there's no
better time to post my own siren head
nothing is as cool as Bionicle siren
head then
now told you 20% muscle increase if you
become a member could should do a music
review his music taste is pretty unknown
my music taste is the absolute worth
worse don't ask
thank you and that's a copyright
nightmare maybe I'll do it on the live
stream actually I did on my live stream
once and I shared a bunch of really
private and songs that meant a lot to me
and no one gave a [ __ ] so [ __ ] you why
am I so aggressive I'm sorry I'm sorry
tambourine of apology tambourine of
apology take exception who are you
you never finished playing me do you
have the slightest idea how little that
narrows it down if Pierce puts mirrors
on the ceiling not only not only he will
protect himself some silly game but also
he'll eliminate silly game and double
the floors you heard that your end of
days is coming
one day I'll install ceiling no way
manga/anime
netflix adaptation see this is more like
it
ridicule thank you no one heals himself
by wounding another doom guy reaper
alright I might not a gamer I'm not a
nerd I don't understand this
and whoever made this should feel bad
tambourine will feel bad news yeah I
hope you feel bad now petition for Felix
to record another r-tx minecraft video I
was supposed to do that but I forgot
because I'm an idiot told you consistent
floor gang idiot because he he had wrong
settings
he had night vision also you should use
correct texture packs it's kind of ugly
you know I saw that Nvidia made like a
poster they made this nice little
montage of the streamers and youtubers
reacting to the r-tx going like it's
like the magic button that just turns on
the awesome me oh it really adds just
this level of gods raise up there huh I
don't know man it doesn't look that good
oh my god you're again what happened to
yeah it's kind of ugly isn't it why do
they call me Nvidia come on guys that's
so unfair I every time they know you
can't just announce your presence in the
distance you need to sneak behind them
haha
sirens go I can make the Sun k cupcake
hoc yeah you should call them that now
triggered after discovering gog is
filthy Frank but you know I knew this is
gonna happen at some point it's kind of
funny though dumbass kids they're so
dumb it's hilarious
we know he moved away from it big deal
you don't need an astronomer astronomer
to explain why the earth is run you need
a psychologist to figure out what's
wrong with Flat Earth nurse well it's
pretty simple just like any self-worth
that you have to make up some sort of
theory that makes you feel like you're
above the rest of the world when in
reality your view of the world it's just
cute and you are dubbed Tambourine of
shape throw the [ __ ] up Felix please
come in bed it's almost been a month all
right whenever I see sheets and detail
I'm like all right that's a pee-pee
that's a people right there my crush her
mom heard that her cuts in her crush me
there you go everyone small neck bad
person everyone knows this look at my
neck what is that look at my neck
three things that are consistent oh my
god love it big beefy we also have the
peepee buns as emojis if you become a
member
link in description hey I'm not trying
to like shame you guys tambourine of
shame but you should definitely check it
out PewDiePie ex Ironhead Fenna that's
really dope I shooting let me look at
that bigger love the collars I'm
extremely thirsty just want that to be
no I wish something could be done about
it
the sacrifices I made and I'm very hot
too god damn it
these bars can't hold me forever there's
only like two of them good your death
dumbass Felix and Marcia's kid he's
about to say all right come on it it's
not funny if I know exactly what the
meme is Tambourine of shame small peepee
just don't waste my time next time
alright try harder have you heard of
subverting expectations comedy huh
trying to make a joke at the same time
it didn't work
can't damnit I'm as bad as you guys
anyone who spams Felix email has very
small peepee and it's sailing gang well
there's apparently a lot of stealing
gangs out there thank you very much I've
changed email you don't have to keep
doing it then why do I care
kara because my feelings are hurt
everybody it's coming it's coming
I spent three months
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
for example ten out of ten hundred at a
hundred well done
Mac Mac ensign check out his channel
I'll link it in below site we'll do it
thank you sad show him some love
please that was so cool amazing this is
why I love love why Bengt
did I just laugh at a fitness and verb
joke Wow I've stooped so low huh
tambourine of shame to myself sad
tambourine noises pity I finally
discovered what happened to minecraft
pet bank finally the media is covering
the real problems hell yeah 9 channel is
waiting for 55 soon ISM for our video
yeah I'll stop being a bad tambourine of
shame alright
in Sweden would say then cement opponent
goth caning Deventer playing it ok
so suck it which is a terrible saying by
the way I hate it
I always hated it but I've got the
goodie bag yeah my mom is an Indian mom
yes George Lucas with 4 billion dollars
and what I'm so confused this is a meme
I'm what petition for inside the
meatball to be the new home for bees
that's not a bad idea actually
alright I might incorporate that Darth
Jesus Christ
that's sick leg theory that's almost
right that's that's the closest we had
so far
well done Becky 669 yeah and to that you
should change you to 69 Becky 69 you're
welcome
peered speaking Russian other 19 year
olds Russian 90 real horrorshow
hey there's more alright dope toilet
gang classic gang
these are really cool I like the designs
a lot sealing gang is too cool I don't
like it it needs to be like inch or
something I don't know when you're
watching Peter
by at 3m he suddenly screams light
enough to wake your parents
I don't scream in my video that was
tambourine of shame my first year with
no balls how to make Swedish meatballs
well clearly furious Pete you didn't
watch my flippin video dish supported
tambourine of shame I never done this
much tambourine of shame you guys are
just a constant stream of bad things
nice to see both youtubers respecting
each other that's big peepee energy
right there gamers helping gamers I
didn't help anything
just keep it up man I drew this and I
thought Felix would find this amusing
enjoy I love the colors that's awesome
big peepee hey tambourine I'm no shame
know about that kind of first time
burning of shame I'm just gonna do it
anyway I'm sorry
can't help it girlfriend you have small
peepee me knowing that Felix said I have
big peepee you underestimate my peepee
size it's the dumbest - I'm ready
disappoint what have we done what have
we done are we proud are we proud of
where we are I'm not I don't feel good
at all I feel terrible I think I think I
should just sigh this site are you doing
the forbidden why everyone support big
Edie yes this is what I've been saying
because he's lagers can't everybody
gangster the five chased hours starts
working then coming back home and seeing
Felix with a rip-off version of himself
named pink I like it it's pixelated say
that's good this one the gamer I'll
speak to the manager
I immediately will be banned I'll call
our demands right now hey there it is
okay you got a look at this
is really dope to another one CGI ass
that's dub I prefer the good camera
quality I said the good camera quality
there it is
I'm so incapable
I like the ground I knew it I know it I
have full faith they were still some
funny memes like that that's great
alright I don't I wanna I don't want to
leave this with a tambourine of
disappointment so we're just gonna end
the video there thank you for watching I
appreciate it hope you had fun I had fun
smash now gently hit the tambourine and
flip and mother flippin brofist man look
who comes as soon as I'm done with every
year you don't like the videos I don't
like when you scream and makes me scared
can I hit your tambourine now hit the
tambourine bruh hell yeah oh you think
your floor gang will prove it
sit down and download pixel ings right
now the fourth chapter is finally out or
say you have it sounds like someone is
in the ceiling
download now or I'll spit on you
you